If you're watching this then I'm not around anymore, but don't spiral don't obsess keep going
So, how are you a good day is where I don't go around wanting to shoot random strangers in the face
And then turn the gun on myself
So I'd leave you a little guides her life without me you're lovely but you're absolutely fucking useless
Stay active it's not ideal to be a fat lazy self-pity in London
I'm not free go and if I was you'd be safety tubby little ginger cunt, you know
How grumpy you get when things don't go your awake. You got such a good heart. You're born like it
You're just decent this is sandy that you could enjoy the roses. Tell us what humanity's a plague
We were disgusting selfish parasite and the world would be a better place without us
That the sort of thing you meant no
Hows Lisa,
oh Jesus she's dead dad,
Bring lisa with you
You can't just go around being rude to people you can then the dog should be on a lead, oh, I'm sorry. Thank you
What he is not a fat hairy nosey cocksucker. Sorry about that
Disgusting if I do and say what the fuck I want and then when it all gets too much. I can always kill myself
It's like a superpower. That's the worst superhero I've ever heard of
Why don't you throw yourself into your work if that's what the press people do?
We're putting out a free local newspaper that no one cares about that's not true
I've seen lonely people people dying people in pain. I think I've ever met anyone quite sad as him
something for your front cover
freddie mercury's tooth
He's disgusting
brian not everyone could get in the paper and not everyone's fingered Jackie Collins. Have you? No
Cheers, okay. See you again